as
an aspiring and chubby student filmmaker
in the 70s and early 80s i was obsessed
with movies
notably monster science fiction and
horror films i would spend my weekends
making super 8 movies using any
technique i could
to kill my friends and blow things up
with sheer and utter realism
but in that era technique
was hard to come by before the internet
and dvd special features demystified
pretty much everything about the process
movies were sort of like crop circles
they were incredibly cool but uh
how the hell did they get there how did
they do that
avenues to unlocking the secrets of
filmmaking were few and far between and
getting professional replies to
critically important questions like
how do you make someone bleed from the
eyeballs
was not easy
it was in 1981 as a ninth grader and how
do i say this insanely rabid dick smith
fan uh having admired his work from
exorcists to the scanners the exorcist
to scanners the godfather altered states
i wrote the man a fan letter never
expecting to hear back
i came home from school one day
and found a small cardboard cardboard
box addressed to me
the return address was dick smith
larchmont new york my heart pounded as i
opened the box
the enclosed note read
dear jj
here's an old but clean tongue from the
exorcist
put peanut butter inside it to stick it
on
moisten inside and sprinkle dental plate
adhesive powder in it
yours dick
my mother was very concerned
who is this man named dick sending you
tongues
one night later that year i was in new
york visiting my grandparents at the
airport uh waiting at the luggage
carousel i spotted a man waiting for his
bags
i had seen pictures of dick smith before
and holy [ __ ] that looked like dick
smith
but how could i be sure
haha
i remembered that mr smith
has four fingers on his left hand
it was like a ludlum novel i slowly
walked around the carousel trying to get
a glimpse
of his left hand and there
i saw it
i was never happier to see a missing
digit
in my life
i was in a room with my hero he was the
beatles to me
and no one in the terminal had a clue i
approached him and introduced myself he
was if this is possible even kinder in
person uh he gave me a pre-release issue
of cine fantastique magazine dick smith
was on the cover they were featuring his
work on altered states
he signed the magazine and encouraged me
to stay creative keep making movies and
if i wanted to continue writing to him
and my correspondence with dicksmith
went on for years
a typical letter reads
dear jj i've just returned from
czechoslovakia doing an age makeup for
amadeus
the hunger comes out april 29th
yes i like savini's book and his working
creep show
yes cable was attached to plunger in
large syringe instead of lever bicycle
cable
keep up the good work best dick
one night at dinner nearly 20 years ago
dick introduced me to another young
filmmaker from mexico who he thought was
an actual genius i met guillermo del
toro that night and our friendship was
sealed through a mutual
reverence of a makeup artist who blew
our minds first with brilliant talent
then with brilliant kindness
it's easy to lavish praise on a man who
created iconic images using human human
faces as his canvas
godfathers and demons creatures and
horrors
a man who attempted on-camera
transformations long before any one of
us
had ever heard of a pixel
but the praise must also i would say
primarily be given to a man who shared
his secrets
encourage the husky jewish boy with the
super 8 camera the mexican wizard with
his journals full of doodles the legions
of fans and colleagues who came to dick
smith
and with only the hope of one day being
able to entertain people
asked
how did you do that
it was dick smith who gave us the
answers
thank you dick
you